sup guys Greg Alba's is John so today I
caught up Greg on some venom information
yeah what's going around circa the
internet I case you guys don't know I
might get some numbers off here I think
about like end of March
John Watts director of spider-man
Homecoming made it very crystal clear
venom does not commit the venom solo
movie nothing to do with the MCU so I
was that was like the main thing I heard
about that yeah was that it's not
related as no spider-man no yeah so
there was the rivers of venom
information being released and John
Wathan
very clear and then a few days ago Kevin
Feige himself said no that's totally
Sony's thing and nothing to do with the
MCU he made it very clear and then
there's this interview that comes out
that I just showed John yeah with Amy
Pascal producer of the spider-man films
including this upcoming venom movie and
Kevin Feige spider and I'm sure you guys
have like seen some memes or Instagram
videos or Facebook post going on about
it with her same no it's definitely
connected and can buy you it's like his
space is not where his base totally
reeks of huh the amount in smile to
cover this up and I'm really listening
now because I don't know what the hell's
you talkative another didn't have it's
pretty funny to watch that video at
least as much as I saw that because like
it seems like each time he doesn't like
uh-huh and then like readjust something
else that makes him do it again because
the heads like what to mix to so much
one-coat video are you talking about and
and this is just made everything more
confusing hey it would be great if venom
is connected to the MCU that is that's
fantastic yeah and that gives us whole
and we could [ __ ] see betterment MCU
there
don't exist without spider-man so yeah
it would make more sense and at the same
time it would just it might be better
overall with what John was said and what
can face it's just a few days before
this interview is making me wonder like
a couple of things one is Amy Pascal's
is wrong this is this do this there's
like big misunderstanding as to what's
going on with the venom project really
she really want this to happen and maybe
by saying that laughter like some source
it's on you're in an interview and
making you to think it that's putting
marble in a position to make this happen
I don't think Kevin fire you would want
the MCU stamp associated with a with a
movie that's only done by Sony
if MCU does not have its creative
control over it what does the thing with
the Marvel movies it's all MCU creative
control well especially after they're
rebooting spider-man a third time and
taking it from Sony hated yeah you know
so if you like I got the impression
there's a pretty decent wedge between
those two companies and you'll see the
Marvel logo just whenever they borrow
theirs yeah I'm kind of there with you
like is she doing that thing of if I
just put it out there I can find you
beside me because you know like
basically they're studio people they can
be kind of manipulative and yeah or
there's some kind of like wood if
they're a surprise or not ever
identified rise waiting to reveal you
know was there going to be some centum
teasing I remain oh god is there
something that she revealed ahead of
time that marvelous was intentionally
keeping hush this whole thing has just
led everything to be exceptionally
confusing because yeah I'm just left on
this on this side this can't fight you
just doesn't look confident in that
video he doesn't look like he's at he's
on board with what she's saying to me
and he was more like maybe Sony just
went ahead and maybe they're doing their
venom movie and they said they think
it's connected but I really don't think
MCU boys are going to be comfortable
with pudding and like their association
because I'm sure that's what's going to
sell it if they're able to get away with
saying this film is connected to the MCU
that'll probably be its biggest sell
yeah you
because and maybe any past will heard
the reactions of people being like what
is this connected on you because I how I
felt
yes like it's how everybody felt that
was like the unit there were two things
about venom the movie one was Tom Hardy
and the other one was spider-man yeah
you know you're not gonna be in this I
want to do this because I want to hear
what you guys think or is there
something we missed
it's just something we missed because I
don't think there is something we miss
there are enough sad Kevin Feige
compilation yeah I feel like this was a
genuine what yeah if you genuinely look
like that's not what we agreed upon with
your venom project yeah what are you
playing in yeah maybe somebody's doing a
film that is connected to the MCU but
the MCU has no creative input on and the
MCU has no creative input on it out of
this is going to make people like Kevin
Feige very happy yeah I don't know it
doesn't seem like these projects are in
any way related any now in a real
spider-man even board what you already
have to do this a third time like please
don't don't make it any weird marbles do
it alright let marble business bedroom
slowly because we've got to come out let
the poster pass us by a hit like
horribly Photoshop posters everybody
lost in my show so let's have the movie
and then worry about this junk wait wait
a minute not even for a while right yeah
even started shooting that was 200 times
we opened in production I think it's
some [ __ ] stunt by her honestly or
she or she is good I just didn't know
maybe yeah maybe yeah movies is not a
lot of communication happening and they
have to release some statements and
there's this whole thing up they have to
release something that clears it up
because yes because even though she said
it and the fact that can find you said
just a few days before this interview
that it's not connected just makes it
all the more confusing because it's so
much back and forth and I'm not going to
be telling people you have Venom's
connected the MCU right now am i I don't
know they even know for sure if it is
right now yeah there may be the only
thing is the only thing that ever
I know at least now is that the Internet
no is that something weird and they're
gonna have to address that yeah I think
this should yeah I do it yeah because
once I feel like once something like
this become the meme you need to address
little Kevin fight he has to address it
I think because he's in the video and he
doesn't want cut her off and go
no no playing playing it profession it's
my unprofessional but he certainly
seemed really caught off guard yeah what
are you guys hi Ben Hardy him subscribe
ever real rejects click that
notification about dad John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum house go check out our
exclusive perks and rewards over at
patreon.com slash the real rejects today